getting your hair styled or your makeup
done if you're a woman in kabul it's
still possible even with the taliban in
power
corners
when the taliban to cover the country in
august beauty salons such as the ones
you see behind me shut down
many of the owners of beauty salons
decided to erase the images of women
they had on their windows to appease the
taliban to avoid retaliation after a few
weeks however
beauty salons started gradually
reopening
and business is now slow in this beauty
center we visited
still salons are pushing to stay open
and testing what they can get away with
in kabul many women are scared of
venturing outdoors on their own these
days
and those who do often dress more
conservatively than in the past
taliban have a more moderate stance on
women than when they were last in power
in the 1990s but they have imposed some
restrictions
barring most female civil servants from
going to work and cracking down on
protesters marching for women's rights
younger girls have been allowed to go to
elementary school
though most middle and high schools
remain shut for the time being
keen to obtain international recognition
and aid the taliban government has
promised to respect women's rights
within the limits of islam
but many remain skeptical
who runs a beauty salon in cabo says she
decided to reopen and continue working
despite the potential risks
foreign
asked about beauty salons a taliban
spokesman told us that under their rule
women will be allowed to get an
education and work
so far there's no indication that these
shops will be forced to shut down
still aquila's business is struggling
she says she's making just around 110
dollars a month down from 2 700 a year
ago
last time they were in power in the
1990s the taliban imposed harsh strict
social rules on women
women were barred from education and
work and could only appear in public if
they were covered from head to toe
they had to be accompanied by a male
guardian
this time around the taliban haven't yet
imposed such strict social rules the new
government is still working to formalize
those kinds of regulations
beauty parlors were also banned when the
taliban last ruled and business owners
like akilah are worried that those harsh
restrictions could be reimposed
foreign
you